well the driver accused of hitting a tow
truck operator and then leaving the
scene is in jail tonight this afternoon
she went before a judge
51 year old colette de spain faces
several charges for the incident tuesday
night that
took the life of 48-year-old ryan
billett christian casada spoke with
spain's son and he joins us live from
the newsroom with
how police managed to track her down
christian that's right denise and brian
colette de spain was arrested last night
after detectives received
an anonymous tip i spoke with her son
today who says he can't comprehend
their new reality now to spain was
dressed in black and
in handcuffs today during her court
appearance now she's charged with
failure to stop at a scene of an
accident
failure to maintain lane improper lane
change failure to give
info at an accident and a probation
violation
according to nhp the spain is the person
who hit and killed
ryan billet the 48 year old tow truck
driver was working near the 215 southern
beltway
and decatur when he was hit despite the
spain's son
jordan shared the moment when he learned
about what happened
when she got home i saw the damage i
couldn't even open the passenger door
she was limping her ankles were swollen
her back was kind of hurting despain
told us several officers mostly
undercover
arrived at their southwest valley home
last night his mother was taken to jail
and the vehicle hauled away neighbors i
spoke to today said that they saw the
police activity
but they're glad that they found the
person responsible now the spain's
next court date is on tuesday christian
casadas 8 news now